Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in the
opening verses of
which is chapter number 73 in the order
of the mus
He says that which translates to
addressing the prophet Sam
saying and calling out to
meaning the one who is wrapped up in his
bedding in his blankets at night in his
bed.
stand in prayer for the duration of the
night save
a portion.
So meaning stand in prayer for the night
except
a portion of it which
at its face value would mean to stand in
prayer for the majority of the night. He
then qualifies this subhanahu wa ta'ala
saying
half of the night or
a little less than half
or a little more than half
and recite the Quran in your prayer
meaning in said prayer.
melodically
and
with a
reasonable pace which we will get into
the details of inshallah. So here he
begins with
for
[Silence]
When Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commands
something, when the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam commands something, this is an
important point that we have to know and
that is what is the
essential nature of a command.
When we have something in the Quran, do
this
or in the sunnah the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam says do something x y and z. Do
the following.
This is a command. Is it obligatory?
What's its ruling? Is its ruling and
it's essential in in
you know for all intents of and
purposes. Is it obligatory?
Is it something which is highly
encouraged? Is it preferable?
The correct opinion is that every
command in the Quran and Sunnah
unless qualified
and unless otherwise stated
is
articulating
obligation.
It's binding.
So the essential nature of a command is
not that it is something which is which
is optional. Any command in the Quran is
obligatory.
Any command from the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and it's you know the the
default of a command is that it is
binding. It is something which is
binding. What does binding mean? binding
or obligatory. What is the ruling of
that? The ruling is that if a person
does it, they are rewarded. If they fail
to do it, then they are held
accountable.
That is the meaning of something being
obligatory. It's something you'll be
asked about. It is something that you do
not have the option of foregoing and
not fulfilling. And the same thing goes
for prohibitions
in the in the Quran when Allah says do
not do
something or the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam says do not do something
the
essence and default nature of a
prohibition is that it is haram.
What is the ruling of haram? What does
that mean? It means that if you do it,
you will be held accountable
and if you refrain from doing it, you
will be rewarded. The exact opposite and
contrast of obligation.
Now this has been directed to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. This
command it was not directed to us and he
was not commanded to instruct us with
the same command. rather he was the one
who received this command.
The scholars all agree
that
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
when he is commanded to do something
in this verse
that this is specific to him
meaning that it is obligatory for him
and it is preferred
for us it's highly encouraged
that's in this verse but in general when
a command is directed to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
It is for him and for us.
It is for him and for us. We know that
this commandment here of standing in
prayer at night is the exception. How do
we know it's an exception to the rule?
Because we have other verses, other
narrations
that articulate
that we are not obligated beyond the
five daily prayers as a daily or nightly
prayer. It is only five. When the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
was asked
about Islam.
He says, "Sallam,
this narration is in Sah Albkari and Sah
Muslim, a
desert man came to the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam and said, "What
has Allah commanded me to do?" He said,
, asking him about Islam, what is it?
What am I expected to do? What is
expected of me? because he had heard of
Islam from the various companions that
the prophet would send to call people to
Islam. So he came to ask for himself
exactly what is required of him. And so
he said
our prophet responded saying
five prayers in every d day and night.
He said
He said, "And am I obligated beyond
those five daily prayers?"
The prophet responded saying, "No,
unless you wish to do more from yourself
optionally."
And there are many many narrations like
this. So the obligatory
repeating
daily and nightly prayers are five. This
doesn't mean that there are no other
prayers that are obligatory.
There are however repeating in every day
and night it is only these five.
So this here is a command to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. It was obligatory
upon him at the beginning of Islam
and in the correct opinion it was always
obligatory upon him until he passed away
sui
this was something that was specific to
him with respect to obligation
as for it being something preferred it's
preferred for everyone but when Allah
commands the prophet with something in
the Quran
That is for him and for us by default.
[Silence]
The commandments that are directed to
him by default include us because we are
his followers saiam
and what he is commanded with we are
commanded with unless there's some
verse or narration elsewhere where that
qualifies this and proves it to be an
exception to that rule.
And we mentioned the stages that Salah
went through.
Who can tell us when the five daily
prayers were obligated?
Huh?
On the night of
correct.
And the night of Isra
was in which year after be which year
after prophethood?
10 the 10th year after he was appointed
a prophet sallallah.aii wasallam.
That's not when salah first began.
Because a person may read this and say,
"Well,
if salah was
obligated on the night of,
then how do we understand these verses?"
We understand these verses as
being that
is on that night he was obligated
the five daily prayers
but before that salah went through
stages.
Number one was this stage here
standing in prayer at night which is
what this chapter revolves around the
second.
Who remembers the second stage?
Huh?
Right. So what what is the verse? Let's
let's hear it.
Huh?
[Silence]
So here he says
That's the second stage.
And then the third stage was
the five daily prayers. Now when he is
commanded with the five daily prayers,
everything else became what?
Everything else was abregated.
And so now what is obligatory is the
five daily prayers
and
remains as something preferable and
you know two or four before or two
after etc. These sunnen they became
something that are preferred as well.
But tells us that when salah was
obligated it was to
and that remains the case for the
traveler but for the resident it is for
as she said and and we went in in great
detail with this. So here Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says half of the
night or a little less
or a little more than half of the night
not the entire night.
There is not a single narration
even herself
has said and there is not a single
instance when the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam spent the entire night in salah.
This did not occur.
Never. Not during Ramadan and not
outside of Ramadan. He may have spent
the entire night in
right where he would pray a large
portion and then the remainder time be
in or recitation or in dua etc.
But standing in salah for the entirety
of the night that is not something that
the prophet did slay.
Do we know the story in the narration of
Annis of the three young men that came
to Isa asking her about the prophets
worship sallallahu alaihi wasallam. We
remember this narration. , three young
men came. One of them when they asked
her about his fasting, asked her about
his salah at night, asked her these
questions.
And so she told them that he would pray
a portion of the night and sleep a
portion and that he would fast some days
and break his fast others. And so it's
as if they found that to be too
little.
Now their thinking, their reasoning is
that
you know that's the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and as they said
Say
[Silence]
and so one of them
said vowed to stand in prayer every
night all night. What does all night
mean? Meaning as soon as the
is completed from that point until the
break of dawn. That's the entirety of
the night. And the second vowed to fast
every single day. And the third vowed to
not marry to remain celibate.
And so the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
heard of this
and he said,
[Silence]
He said,
"I fast some days and break my fast
others and I pray a portion of the night
and I sleep a portion and I merry. I am
not celibate." And so whoever desires a
sunnah other than mine, whoever whoever
desires other than my sunnah, then he is
not one of me. He's not of me. He is not
of me.
And so here the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam we understand from this that he
was never commanded to pray all night.
This is a type of extremism
and extremism is always what is always
denounced by Islam.
tells us that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said anyone
who is extreme this person is upon
misguidance
extremism.
How can a person extreme
in the teachings of the Quran?
Allah says,
Allah says, "Stand
stand in prayer for a portion of the
night." They say, "No, I'll stand all of
the night."
Allah commands fasting the month of
Ramadan. They say, "No, I'll fast every
single month, every day." Right?
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
commands that we say
100 times in the morning, 100 times in
the evening. They say, "No, I'll do it a
thousand. I'll do it 10,000 times.
That's not enough for me. That's too
little. I'm I'm stronger than that. I'm
better than that. I am special."
And this is what is dangerous. when a
person becomes extreme
in the teachings of the Quran because
extremism
is always denounced
in anything.
What if what if a person were to become
extreme in drinking water? Is there
anything better for your body than
water? I can't hardly think of anything
better for your body than water. Or even
the water of Zam.
Let's say instead of drinking a gallon
of water a day, you say, "Well, Zam, I'm
going to drink 10 gallons, 15 gallons of
Zam every day." What's going to happen
to this person?
He's going to die because there is
something there is such a thing as water
poisoning.
Water po. Yes, water poisoning. And it's
fatal 99.9%
of the time.
Why? Because this is extremism.
We are taught that extremism destroys.
And so
Allah then commands him,
recite the Quran with with what is tart?
[Silence]
What is a tal is that a person recite
with an even pace and that they not
be rushing in their recitation. ation. A
man came to
and we will end with this inshallah
and he said
I recited tonight in my prayer all of
anyone know where starts and ends of the
Quran.
Let's see if we have some
Quran. Yes.
What?
That's not very impressive.
I recited four pages of the Quran
tonight. No,
because the Quran's divided into four
four parts.
The first part which is the seven
longest, then a second part, then a
third part and then aluas.
Al- Muas is specific to the prophet
sallall.aii.
Mufas starts
at
some scholars say Mu starts at which is
the next chapter over this portion of
the Quran is roughly the last fourth of
the Quran in that categorization.
So from
to the end which is about four roughly
give or take. That's actually not a
little bit, that's a lot for a person to
recite in salah at night.
And so
he said,
he said, "This recitation is fast, too
fast the recitation of poetry."
He said, "Do not recite the Quran that
quickly."
And so tomorrow night inshallah ta we
will discuss the
exact method that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam used to recite the
Quran. How much he would recite every
day and night. What he would recite. How
much he would recite at night and how
the speed of his recitation was.
Because the speed of his recitation has
been preserved by the scholars
by the companions
and exactly how the speed was of his
recitation
subala
and
[Arabic recitation]